من الصعب حقًا الوصول إلى
جولة pj ،
أعتقد أن الكثير من الجمهور يرى الكثير من
مشجعي لعبة الجولف أفضل اللاعبين
في العالم أه
أنت تعرف الرجال الذين يبلغون من العمر 21 عامًا
ويخرجون من الكلية مبكرًا ،
أنت تعلم أنهم  حقق نجاحًا فوريًا في
الفوز بالتخصصات ،
لكن هذا ليس واقعًا بالنسبة
لغالبية لاعبي الجولف
وأغلبية الرياضيين ، لذا فأنت تعرف أن
الرجال الذين تعرفهم
كانوا مثلي ،
وكانوا لا يعرفون أبدًا ما إذا كنت
ستنجح في تحقيق ذلك ، فأنت لا تعرف أبدًا ما إذا  ستحصل
على هذا الأسبوع الرائع ، تعلم
أنك كنت أعرف دائمًا أنني أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك ، كنت
أعرف دائمًا أنني أمتلك القدرة ، لكن
تلك الشكوك تتسلل إليها نوعًا
ما خرجت
مني ، ثم أفكر فيك
العائلة وكل
القرية بأكملها في المنزل في
بلاكسبيرغ فيرجينيا مما جعل ذلك
ممكنًا ،
لقد رأيت الكثير من مقاطع الفيديو التي تعرفها
من بعض الأصدقاء الذين كانوا
يشاهدون حفلات يوم الأحد وكانوا
جميعًا يقفزون صعودًا وهبوطًا وكانوا
يخافون نوعًا ما  حول الفوز
أنا  يبدو الأمر وكأنني دفعت لهم المال
يوم الأحد في هيوستن ، الطريقة
التي بدأت بها لعبة الجولف
هي أمر مفجع ، ولكن أيضًا يثلج الصدر ،
هل يمكنك أن تشرح
لنا ولمشاهدينا كيف بدأت ،
نعم ، لقد توفي والدي عندما
كان يبلغ من العمر 12 عامًا ،
وعندما مرض بسرطان الدماغ ،
بدأ في ممارسة لعبة الجولف ، فاشترى لي ،
أول مجموعة لي من الأندية
التي لم يلعبها أبدًا ، كنت دائمًا ألعب
كرة السلة وكرة
القدم البيسبول ، كانت تلك الرياضات الرئيسية الثلاث التي
أمارسها ،
وقد دربني والدي  لذلك أنت تعلم
أنه عندما مرض ، اضطررت للتوقف عن لعب
كرة القدم والسفر والسفر ، والسفر ، والسفر ،
وكرة السلة ، لأننا
لا نستطيع تحملها ، وواحد
تعرفه ، كان والدي هو الشخص الذي
تعرفه دائمًا أخذني على الطريق
وسافر معه
لقد عرّفني على ستيف
فرويدر في نادي بلاكستون الريفي وعندما رحل عني ،
منحني ستيف فرايتر عضوية كاملة
بعد 17 عامًا بعد 17 عامًا لم
يكلفني أبدًا أي درس.
مجرد تحويل مأساة
إلى حياتي ، لذا عندما أنظر إلى الوراء في مسيرتي
المهنية ،
فأنت تعلم أنه بدون رحيله في
تلك المأساة بأكملها ، لم
أكن لأكون لاعب غولف
أبدًا ، كما قلت إن ستيف لم يكلفك أبدًا
مقابل درس في الجولف ، كيف
ستفعل  إن الأمر متروك له ، أنا متأكد
من أنه منذ الأسابيع الخمسة الماضية
تلك الـ 17 عامًا من الدروس ،
أعتقد أنني
سأدفع له مقابل ذلك إذا أخذنا
كل الساعات
التي أعطاها لي ، أعتقد أننا عدنا إلى  على
الأقل حتى الآن ،
سيكون عيد الميلاد جميلًا ،
سيكون أسهل فحص
كتبته
في حياتي وأنا متحمس له فقط ،
وأنا متحمس له للحصول على بعض
الدعاية لأنه كان وراء هذا
النوع  من وراء الخطوط يقوم بتعليم
الكثير من المبتدئين المبتدئين
أم فقط لاعبي الغولف العاديين لديك وأنت
تعلم أن الرجل يمكنه الجلوس في ميدان
القيادة لمدة 10 ساعات لتعليم
المبتدئين طوال اليوم ولا يزال
الشخص الأسعد الأكثر رعاية لا
يشعر بالإحباط
حتى يكون قادرًا  لوضعه قليلا
في الهزلي  ht وانظر إلى ما
أعادته إلى لعبة الجولف
وقد غير الكثير من حياته حقًا أه
فقط من لاعب الجولف العادي
لقد جعل الناس يرغبون في لعب الجولف
وهذا ما يحتاجه الجولف إلى المزيد من
الأشخاص مثل ستيف فراتر لذا
فهو رائع جدًا.  لقد
فكرت كثيرًا في
ما ستكون عليه حياتك
الآن وماذا يمكن أن تحققه أيضًا
لا أعتقد بصراحة
أنه سيتغير كثيرًا
ولكنك تعلم أنني سأحصل عليه
مزيدًا من الاهتمام ، سأكون في
السنوات الثلاث المقبلة ، سأكون في
جولة PGA لكنني كشخص سأكون
كما تعلم ، لن أغير كل شيء
وأنت  اعرف ما إذا كنت فزت بـ
20 حدثًا آخر في جولة pga أو هذا
بالنسبة لي ،
فأنا لا أعتقد أنه سيكون
له تأثير كبير
على حياتي ، لكن هذا هو أه
هذا ما تصنعه الأحلام منك
فقط  فائزًا في جولة pga
لبقية حياتي لن أنساها أبدًا
، وأه هذا الجانب الذي يكون هذا
الجانب صعبًا  يا صدقني